the guys beat here so even though Twin
Peaks is a weekly show that will air on
Sundays on Showtime subscribers to show
times streaming services we're able to
watch episodes three and four so this
will be my recap and review for episode
three and definite spoiler warning here
if you haven't watched episode three
then you're going to wait until it
debuts this Sunday before you come back
and watch this video so first off I have
to admit this was my least favorite of
the new episode but it did have its
moments the biggest problem I had with
it was the opening sequence which lasted
about 15 minutes it's not that it was
bad necessarily it was mysterious and
creepy but most of what happened seemed
unimportant to the overall story
basically we found out agent Cooper was
not yet in the real world we picked up
with his following from the lodge as he
was going through the sky and he passes
through a transitional place which I
don't really know how to describe in all
his time there all that really happens
is he passes through with some help from
two unknown characters who aren't
necessarily important to the story going
forward some other notable things that
happened while he's there is he sees a
disembodied head or I should say the
disembodied head of major Briggs in the
cosmos kind of in the background of the
space there and mr. Briggs just says
blue rose and we also find out that the
you know why the arm mentioned 253 which
was in fact of time and that time is
when a big event happens back in the
real world we see evil coupe losing it
while he's driving at the same time he
seems to be on that same Highway we saw
on that in the last episode and he's
basically just starting to lose
consciousness I guess would be the way
to describe it
he eventually crashes his car which was
done really well I mean it was an
awesome crime scene and we get any
awesomely gratuitous puking scene where
he loses what looks like Garmin Rosia
most importantly we see what his plan
was for avoiding going to the Black
Lodge as he's fighting to hold in the
bomb entry we rewind
just a little bit and we meet dougie now
we don't get to learn a lot about dougie
at first but Mike will still listen
later and initially it looks as though
we have a third Cooper albeit a heavier
Cooper that has even a funnier haircut
than evil coop does all we get to know
about dougie in his short time is that
he hangs out with high-end escorts and
when we first meet him he's with Jade
who is a prostitute and they are in a
unrented home somewhere in the Las Vegas
area almost immediately after we meet
him he starts to get sick and we see him
crawl through the house until he vomits
and then we see the curtains and he gets
pulled into the lodges while their mic
fills us in on what's going on he is at
an actual third Cooper but a
manufactured version of Cooper that we
end up assuming that the evil coupe used
as a decoy or you know a replacement as
the evil coupes in the car we see Dudley
behind the curtains and we have to
imagine that he was supposed to get
sucked in because just a little bit
later we see the real agent Cooper take
Dougie's place he comes out of an
electrical outlet and then he
materializes completely only he's lost
something in the transition he's
basically a bumbling idiot at this point
who doesn't know much of anything and
can only just repeat what other people
say for the most part even though he
looks completely different has a
different haircut and is wearing
different clothes jade has no problem
thinking that he's Dougie and when she
realizes he doesn't know what he's doing
she just basically throws him in the car
and takes him somewhere to dump him off
in that process we learned that dougie
head is in some trouble of some sort
with some shady dudes who seem to want
to kill him but we don't know why
Lucky's cars left behind and we see that
someone puts a ball or at least what
looks like a bomb underneath it and we
meet a character who lives across the
street briefly meth-head whose kid kind
of watches that all go down
sure if that will be important later or
not back on the highway the State Police
or the police actually show up to where
evil coupe has wrecked and the first
officer on the scene gets violently ill
from smelling the smell from the garment
Azia in the car back at the Twin Peaks
Sheriff's Department we see that talk
has convened with Lucy and Andy and
they've laid out all the information
they had from Cooper stuff and this
scene kind of drags on a little bit too
because they don't really make any
progress there's some funny bits here
and you know it's typical Andy and Lucy
but the overall thing is is that they're
trying to figure out how Hawk can use
his heritage to figure out what's
missing and all the evidence we get a
little bit of dr. Jacoby who has a
really elaborate setup to paint those
shovels he had in Episode one and he's
paying them gold these couple guitar
pedals hooked up to a machine that he
made and he's just sort of painting them
but we don't have any idea of why he's
doing that at this time Jay drops dougie
or actually agent Cooper off at a small
casino outside of Las Vegas gives him
$5.00 and tells him to go ask for help
or call for help I should check inside
we get a better idea that he really is
not functional at the moment but he has
the strange vision where he can see a
little thing above slot machines that
are about to hit so he basically wins a
bunch of money while he's there he
basically becomes mr. jackpots which
we'll talk about a little bit later and
it's not really an essential part of
anything but it's there's some funny
parts in it especially the old lady who
is the slot addict back at the FBI
headquarters we meet a character that
you might not know or if you have read
the secret history it's the person who
Cole has given a dossier to she's the
one who does all the annotations of TP
and the margins and her name is Tamara
Preston we meet her with two of my
favorite characters of all time Gordon
Cole and all Albert Rosenfeld
so they're at the FBI's headquarters and
Tamara who goes by Tammy is working with
Cole and Albert she goes over the
details of what happened in New York and
we see a little bit of that which we
already saw and then we find out that
evil coupe is in custody when Cole gets
a telephone call the episode ends with
Cole towing Albert and Timmy that
they'll be going with him to the Black
Hills of South Dakota to look into
what's going on with coop who they
haven't seen for 25 years as mentioned
he's in custody so they set up a thing
to fly in the morning and then we cut
back to the Roadhouse where we get
another end sequence song and it looks
like this is going to be a regular thing
throughout the season each episode will
end with a song like I said at the
beginning it's not my favorite episode
the second watch was more enjoyable than
the first it's definitely great to see
Cole and Albert back and and even though
the story didn't move along that far we
did get some information like we figured
out what 2:53 was we figured out what
evil coups plan was to stay in the real
world rather than going back to the
lodge and even though the dougie thing
starts out kind of slow it will
eventually have a big part because
obviously coop is now being regarded as
Dougie says he can't really explain to
anyone that he's not I've already
watched the fourth episode so I can't
really speculate too much without giving
away stuff that's going to happen so
this will be a little bit shorter I
won't go too deeply into any of that
kind of stuff please subscribe to the
channel and make sure you check back
because I have some other twin peaks'
videos on the way
definitely will be coming out with this
the episode 4 recap and review plus some
other ones that I'm doing coming up with
us I'm going along if you have any ideas
of stuff you want to learn more about or
questions about any of these episodes
make sure you leave a comment and I'll
try to get back to you as soon as I can
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon